in 1815 Mount Tambora erupted in
Indonesia killing an estimated 92
thousand people it was the biggest
eruption in recorded history and yet
Tambora was about 1/7 the size of the
smallest supervolcano
there are about a dozen of these
monsters worldwide and the last one went
off twenty six thousand five hundred
years ago in New Zealand blanketing most
of its island in a layer of thick ash
now it's extremely unlikely that one of
these super volcanoes would go off
anytime soon let alone multiple
eruptions at once but for curiosity's
sake what would happen if all the
world's super volcanoes erupted at once
[Music]
if every supervolcano went off you'd
have a hard time finding a safe place to
flee to because almost every continent
is home to at least one supervolcano for
example there is a Yellowstone in the
u.s. in Goro Goro in Tanzania and Toba
in Indonesia so basically no matter
where you are you're out of luck but at
least you'll have a warning because
weeks or months beforehand the ground
will tremble with earthquakes then when
day arrives the earth-shattering sound
would be a dead giveaway that something
wasn't right when Krakatoa which wasn't
even close to the size of a supervolcano
erupted in 1883 it released a roar so
loud the sound traveled nearly four
thousand eight hundred kilometers across
the Indian Ocean shattering windows and
deafening people in its path and since
even the smallest super eruption would
dwarf Krakatoa's eruption there is
really no telling how much damage this
would cause but it would be ethically
catastrophic and let's say you were
lucky enough to survive this first wave
of destruction after that it would be
time to find a fallout shelter because
these super eruptions spew billions of
tons of ash volcanic glass and Rock
thousands of meters into the air not
something you want to inhale or be in
the path of since this cloud of ash
doesn't just travel up it also expands
out crashing across the landscape and
jet fighter speeds it would collapse
buildings contaminate water supplies and
bring down any power grids in its path
and the fallout would extend for
hundreds of kilometers so any cities
near by a supervolcano are immediately
toast as are any planes that attempt to
fly people away from the danger and keep
in mind that ash travels when Toba
erupted 74,000 years ago winds blew ash
all the way to India so if all the super
volcanoes go off at once volcanic debris
would spread across the globe when the
eruption ends the disaster will have
only just started because for the next
six months much of that super volcanic
ash would linger in the stratosphere and
block sunlight causing global
temperatures to plunge by as much as 15
degrees Celsius that's close to the
difference between summer and Rio
versus Anchorage Alaska in fact just
little
Mount Tambora eruption alone set off the
year without a summer where Frost's and
blizzards plagued much of the northern
hemisphere so multiply that by the
twelve or so supervolcano is all spewing
thick black dust and you've got a
worldwide volcanic winter for the next
few years
tropical forests which can't handle cold
weather would wither and die bringing
down the millions of animal species that
live there and it's about to get even
leaker you know that singing out of the
frying pan and into the fire well in
addition to ash those volcanoes also
belch toxic gases like sulfur dioxide
into the atmosphere and after a few
years just after the winter finally ends
those gases would start to fall from the
sky as acid rain when the locky volcano
erupted in 1783 in Iceland
it rained down so much sulfuric acid at
a devastated farmland and wiped out half
of all livestock the next year a full
quarter of Iceland's population died in
the resulting famine so imagine that but
everywhere
and since locky wasn't even a super
volcano we're lookin at acid rain for
the next decade say goodbye to
civilization because it probably can't
survive a decade-long global famine now
there are a few places on earth that
while still suffering from cold and acid
rain and famine would at least be free
from the actual explosions themselves
like volcanic islands such as the
Galapagos or even Hawaii which
ironically is famous for its volcanoes
but the thing is these volcanoes slowly
release flows of lava rather than
violently exploding so you could at
least enjoy a nice view as civilization
implodes
you